[Music]
we begin why don't you kick us off this
first piece is called
father time I'm staring at the number
wondering flash a call I can hear the
tick-tock from the clock on the wall as
it meshes with the thump thump beat of
my heart sometimes getting something
started is the hardest part I didn't
meet my dad until I was 15 I'd seen his
photograph but his image was sickening a
coward with a dick but no balls to back
it up see when he left me as a kid I had
cause for acting up the funny thing
about hate is the person you hate
doesn't feel that hate you feel that
hate but wait the wait can be too much
for a person to take and personally I
was hurt so I just locked it away
I was angry all the time and I didn't
know why I couldn't handle my own rage
so I would hide it inside pretending
everything was fine became a daily
pastime time passed and I started to
believe in my own lies I took it out on
my mom because she raised me alone the
rage that I couldn't own had left me
totally numb it was like laying mines in
my mind that I didn't understand so when
the boy inside cried the young man
outside yelled I think I learned about
my masculinity from TV the people
weren't real so I knew they couldn't
leave me I would sit there for hours
right in front of the tube the images
that I saw were my depiction of truth it
was manhood in a box and I bought into
it
the censorship of anything inside of me
that sensitive the sentence is a
lifetime of tears suppressed in a
stone-faced an overblown ego they've
distracted through a Paper Chase back
when I was nine I imagined in my mind
that my father was a spy working for the
FBI and that's why I couldn't stop by a
writer drop a line he was off saving our
lives from the bad guys but that was
just a lie that I used to get by so that
you wouldn't see the tears welling up in
my eyes when you're rejected by the
person that you created by you secretly
feel like you don't have a right to your
life I thought if I confronted him then
it would make it all right but since I
couldn't forgive him it just recycled my
spite I remember meeting him for the
first time every time a person passed by
I would ask mom is that him I look a
little like him right no oh what about
that guy that was what it was like to
meet the man that gave me my life to
shake his hand and look into his eyes we
talked till he apologized then said our
goodbyes I walked away on my own then I
began to cry now four years after that I
acted like it was all resolved I told
him what I thought so I figured problem
solved but it just revolves my
insecurities were eating at my mental
health I took it out on the world
because I hated myself that's when I
finally decided I needed some help I
opened up I started writing and sharing
about my past
I got honest with myself and I started
chipping at my mask I looked into the
mirror and confronted what I
accepting the reflection by embracing
every flaw then directing the connection
into breaking down the walls by
reflecting the perfection of the God
inside us all
I stopped focusing on everything that I
had been hateful for and started
focusing on everything that I could be
grateful for and personally there is a
lot I can be thankful for if pain is
dragging you down just cut the ankle
cord that's when the weight lifted and I
really started living that's when my
hate shifted and I really started giving
it's when my fate twisted it was like an
ego exorcism your mind state can be the
most powerful of Prisons my father never
played catch with me or gave advice but
if nothing else that man gave me my life
and that's enough from me if that is all
he could ever give because I'm
appreciative for every day I get to live
and even though I don't need my dad to
validate me I thought that I should
write this poem to thank him for
creating me because every moment that we
are alive is like a gift and if that's
not enough to forgive then what is I'm
staring at the number wondering if I
should call I can hear the tick-tock
from the clock on the wall as it meshes
with the thump thump beat of my heart
sometimes getting something started is
the hardest part I picked the phone up
the dial tone begins to sing I punch his
number in to it and it begins to ring
[Music]
ring ring
hello Mike hey man it's uh it's Adam
your son
it's all in there man there's a whole
life packed into that poem yeah and I've
heard you perform it a number of times
every time I hear it I get something new
and more nuanced out of it and then
reading it on the page is a whole
different experience I'm sort of you
probably saw me I was like tracking it
on the page as you were as you were
reciting it and it just continues to
kind of reveal itself so thank you you
know there's a lot of layers to it and
there's a whole like your hope like your
whole life story is basically in there
yeah you know what I mean and it
continues to reveal itself to me too how
has that evolved and changed because you
wrote this a while ago right yeah I mean
everything that I write is really
something that I need to be reminded of
right on a moment-to-moment basis so I'm
doing myself a favor getting to perform
these things to other oh yeah
and I guess you know the meaning changes
as I change I noticed different things
in there
at the beginning I think it was
inspirational and aspirational mm-hmm
and now more and more I think I'm able
to embody a lot of the lessons that I'm
talking about at least in that specific
poem and in that specific situation yeah
I mean I would say the predominant theme
of that is is forgiveness forgiveness of
your father of course but also self
forgiveness yeah but packed into that is
you know the obstacles that you had to
face and overcome within yourself to get
to that place there's a humility and
Anna Anna and you know a beauty to it
and and a journey of transformation
there's you know there's there's a lot
of subplots and sub-themes that are at
play as well yeah and I mean it's made
me who I am in many ways you know this
Rattata team so your attitude
yeah gratitude and forgiveness I mean
I've one of the main avenues to
forgiveness is gratitude you know it's
looking at something that was painful
for you and seeing it from the
standpoint of look at everything that I
was able to
learn from that situation look at Who I
am because of that you know and who
would I be without that situation I mean
I certainly don't think that I would
have been a poet yeah because it forced
me to be internal and to observe myself
and my environment in a way that I don't
think I would have experienced had I
felt safe and comfortable growing up but
at some point you had to grab a lifeline
and do that work yeah add to that place
yeah for sure
and you know if I hadn't then you know I
think maybe it could have been something
that buried me yeah rather than
something that transformed me but I
would say that writing the poem and then
sharing the poem has been a part of that
process mm-hmm so it just kind of
reinforces that that that level of
forgiveness when perhaps a little
resentment creeps in or a little bit of
anger you can remember that poem recited
in front of a crowd or perhaps to
yourself yeah and I think in that
specific situation I've done so much
work around it I do feel at peace yeah
you know until maybe I don't write right
for the most part when I say that that
feels true to me right now when I think
of you and how I experience you is
somebody who is very present incredibly
gracious giving grateful compassionate
and and and curious like there's a
twinkle in your eye like when I'm with
you like I know you're here with me
you're not elsewhere maybe you are in
the recesses of your mind but you're one
of the most present people I know and I
know that that doesn't occur by itself
and I know you weren't born that way
like there's a lot that has to be
undertaken I'm sure on a daily basis to
inhabit that kind of headspace well
first of all I have the same experience
with you I own my own inner monologue of
how I present myself is very different I
promise but that's the same exact way
that I feel I think it's probably rare
that you would meet someone where you
know they're complete perception and how
the world
use them is aligned with their personal
perception of themselves because they
hear all of the noise they have to sift
through in order to decide how to show
up and be their best version of who they
can be at that moment and continue to
try to evolve that potential you know I
definitely do practices around that you
know we've talked about that many times
from meditation to yoga to having
different coaches and all sorts of areas
of my life that hopefully helped me to
continue to evolve and move towards that
better version of myself and then I
would say poetry has been a real
trampoline to that in every area because
it's forced me to be self aware in a way
that I would say nothing else has but
you know even as you were saying all of
that stuff the joke that was running
through my head is well what you say I
wasn't listening you know yeah I mean of
course we still have all of those other
internal dialogues going on and we have
to almost continue to let go of them so
that we can show up in the moment in a
weird way I mean that's what meditation
is it's like a gym for letting go we
practice letting go of our thoughts and
our emotions so that we can arrive and
be more present mm-hmm before we get any
deeper into this I just I have to just
publicly acknowledge you with a little
gratitude for the ways in which you've
shown up for me in my life particularly
coming out on the night of the the live
event in LA and then it just it just you
know put the evening over the top and
I'm just I'm so thankful that you were
kind enough to show up and bless
everybody with your gift Thank You Man
first of all it's my pleasure and I feel
the exact same way once again about you
I feel like you've been generous to me
in you know countless ways in our
friendship and I think that's one of the
reasons that I love being around you
this because I'm inspired to return to
my own generosity in that way the other
thing is I very much respect what you've
built I really do
I respect who you are in the world how
you show up and the things that you
continue to explore and create for other
people so for me to get an opportunity
to show up and to perform for your
audience I mean that's a blessing for me
as
well I appreciate that when I think
about your particular form of art and
creative expression it's something that
that is so difficult for me to imagine
being able to do like it's so distant
from my own personal skill set and I was
reminded of it
when I was in I was in New York City a
number of months ago and I went to go
see my buddy
Karsh perform at freestyle Love Supreme
okay cause that show easy it just it
just rocked me yeah to my core I was
literally a gape the entire time just
delighted at what I was seeing unfold in
front of me and for people that don't
know it's a it's a freestyle rap musical
spoken word kind of performance with an
ensemble cast that includes her car
she's been on the podcast
lin-manuel Miranda showed up there's a
couple other cats and they you know they
lob stuff up out to the audience and
they get a bunch of participation from
people and then they take these little
pieces or facets of people's stories and
in real time
weave it into essentially a you know
one-act musical spontaneous performance
of singing dance rap spoken word that
just comes out of nowhere right now and
it's so amazing to watch somebody watch
a group of people with that level of
facility perform in that manner because
it's like I said it's so distant from
anything I could ever imagine being able
to do and although what you do is a
little bit different from that I mean
you come from that tradition like you're
very connected to freestyling and
hip-hop and the rap scene and all of
that so I mean how do you know is it is
it is it a gift is it a skill is it both
like how do you develop that ability to
you know react in in that kind of
artistic way well first of all I didn't
see the show but I heard but you can
imagine I mean you have a sense of what
it is yeah yeah absolutely doing
lin-manuel Miranda's a brilliant
brilliant artist
and I've heard that the show is
mind-blowing
so I actually really wanted to see I'm
going to New York tomorrow right yeah
it's over yeah exactly
so off the wait until they do it again
but I mean I started out freestyling
it's certainly not you know the main
focus of my career at this point it's
not even something that I practice on a
regular basis but that was my first form
of meditation you know I fell in love
with hip-hop and you know I just started
the process of freestyling by myself and
then in ciphers and then battling and I
mean there is nothing super present to
do that well that's why it really was
the first form of meditation for me
because it's just I mean you cannot
think about anything else but the next
word and the next run you know and so it
puts you so in the present moment like
nothing else at least in my life at that
time ever had and the other thing is is
that you know it's almost like a dump of
your unconsciousness you know coming out
through your freestyles and so there's
this a crazy experience of release when
you're freestyling and so all of the
maybe thoughts and emotions that I
didn't have another outlet for at that
time you know with the different things
that I already discussed in the poem and
other things that were going on in my
life growing up this was my release and
you know it was it was my religion at
the time well there was a pivotal moment
in your kind of career evolution right
that involved freestyling what remind me
I think you told a story when you were
coming up when you were young
where you had the opportunity to like go
on stage and I don't know if it was like
a battle rap thing or whatever but it
was it was a symbolic in that it showed
you that you could do this yeah I
remember in that Kris funny because I
hadn't I I don't I haven't really
thought of that story in a long time but
yeah I was like 15 and I was at a club
and ended up battling this guy on stage
and you know it was just a crazy
experience to watch you know the 250 300
people that were there
respond to something that was coming out
you know out of my mind and out of my
heart and you know to win it's different
to when you know in a cypher than it is
to win on stage in front of a real
audience and I think that was a pivotal
moment of empowerment for me and I think
ultimately that what I wound up later at
the first poetry open mic that I went to
which is called the poetry lounge and
it's every Tuesday night at the
green-white Court Theatre and it turned
out to be by the way the biggest open
mic in the entire country it was 350
people every single week that would show
up to watch people perform their poems
from signing up on a list and I just
literally showed up there one night and
I started doing my rapping acapella
and that was the first time that I had
ever seen people respond the way that
people responded in battle raps for
example but to vulnerability mmm-hmm it
was like when somebody got up and they
said something that was true the whole
audience would be like oh you know I
mean because that a connection
yeah the mirror of their own humanity
you know sharing something that was so
true that it made the audience feel less
alone there was something really
beautiful and powerful and inspiring
about that night I literally want every
single week from then on yeah well
vulnerability is at the core of
everything that you do yeah I mean I try
to be as open with myself as I can
through my work because I think the more
open that I am the more that it at least
opens up a window for someone else's
healing
yeah gives people permission and a safe
place to experience those emotions in
their own life yeah for sure
you know yeah that's a huge part of of
these workshops that you do I did one of
your poetry workshops I think it was at
that that conscious capitalism yeah yeah
that I do I know you do these all the
time yeah but there was something just
so magical about seeing this group of
people they're all like CEOs and
like that yeah you creating this like
crucible of safety to allow them to
explore their imagination in a way that
you know maybe they had never done
before and then encouraging them to you
know share these poems that they would
work on over the course of the afternoon
and then receive the the support and the
cheers and the kind of love from the
group was incredibly enriching
experience and I'm sure you see this you
know you do this all the time so it's
got to be just as gratifying for you as
it is for the people who are
participating yeah I mean it's it's a
really beautiful experience and it's
something that I stumbled across I mean
I I never almost like anything else in
my career intended it to be what it is
you know I certainly didn't set out and
think I'm gonna be a professional poet
anyway that wasn't even a [ __ ]
possibly I don't so what I mean when
you're at a cocktail party and somebody
says what you what do you do like how do
you answer that well I mean I'm a poet
I mean it's equally as ridiculous as
saying you're a racecar driver like
people look at you like what do you mean
you and I think you're more likely to
meet a racecar driver than I know one
race car driver so you know I think it
depends upon whether or not I want to
talk about myself right you know if I
say I'm a poet usually you know people
are so dumbfounded that it becomes kind
of like the center of the conversation
right you can't just go oh cool and move
on right right so you're either the
biggest douche in the universe
exactly you know I'm either that or I'm
something else but you know or both so
you got to read the room yeah of course
and read myself do I want to actually
have this conversation right now or you
know I want to just say oh I'm a
songwriter and then you know blah blah
blah and I can switch the subject pretty
quickly if I want to but how did it come
up like oh will you teach will you teach
people how to do this like how did that
arise well you know when I was in my 20s
and I was trying to figure out how I was
going to monetize this passion of mine I
was open to anything you know because I
was just trying
to make rent you know I'd make write
pretty much any consistent money until I
was 30 years old or something like that
and and so one of the things that I
wound up doing I had an opportunity to
perform and do these workshops at a
place called our chair and I just
stopped by there the other day I had to
do something downtown and it's an
amazing amazing artists like community
and commune and they had a bunch of kids
that would come in from East LA and so
for about four or five years I would run
these workshops with these kids and we
would explore all the things that were
going on in their lives and then I was
doing Upward Bound which is for kids
that you know their parents had never
gone to college they were the first
generation and their families that were
going to college and so I started doing
these poetry workshops with them
and so originally it was just for people
that were younger and they were figuring
out their lives and I did it over and
over and over again and you know all
sorts of different environments and
ultimately I ended up getting
opportunities to do it with adults too
and I realized that adults needed it
sometimes just as much or more right
then then kids did and so having an
opportunity to provide a space for
people to explore moments that changed
who they are in front of strangers that
very quickly become family because we
realized that even if the circumstances
are different the humanity is the same
mm-hmm is it been an absolute honor you
know and people come up to me over and
over again that they've experienced
something from the workshop and made
major life changes based on something
that they explored through their poem
and they thanked me for it and I'm like
I literally feel like all I did was
provide a space for them to hear their
own voice mm-hmm you know we were
talking about that before the podcast
started the technology is amazing as a
tool but there's a difference between
you using a tool and the tool using you
and we're not sitting with ourselves and
hearing our own voices very often
anymore and so I think that the
poetry workshop is a doorway into people
doing that and there's usually very
surprised and moved by about what comes
up yeah a couple thoughts I mean I think
you're correct in that you know we do
have these amazing tools with technology
that allow us to create on a level
unprecedented in the history of
humankind the flip side or dark side of
that is that and we were talking about
this previously also is that you
actually have to create structures
around them in order to engage your
imagination otherwise you're constantly
stimulated by you know scrolling on this
app or that right and to do what you do
requires you know I would imagine a lot
of you know deep introspection and quiet
time in order for these thoughts to
congeal into words and phrases that you
know end up coming out of your mouth or
on the page and you know if you're
constantly distracted you're never able
to basically grapple with that with that
voice and that's my concern for myself
yeah because I know what it's like to
try to do battle with technology in
order to find quiet time but also with
the younger generation that's never
known differently right yeah exactly I
mean look the way that I even write
poems in the first place is I just pay
attention you know I mean if something
inspires me or moves me or annoys me
usually that's the beginning of a poem
and so I just kind of stay aware and
when one of those things happens I will
write it down and if I write it down and
I start the poem in a place that's true
and then I give it time and space the
rest of the poem will almost write
itself
mmm you know I consider myself like the
vehicle and the obstacle for these poems
to come into the world I mean they come
through me and through my perception but
I also have to get in the way or get out
of the way the way in order for them to
really show up the way that they want
and sometimes I'll write something and
it's dope you know but it's more about
me than it is about the poem it's not
right mm-hmm
you know it's
but it's not right so I have to go no
this is what the poem actually wants to
say and to bring it full circle you know
writing this book was a really
fascinating process for me because
because I start always in just a place
that's true I don't really strategize my
inspiration I'm not like this is what I
want to say I'm usually surprised by
where the poem goes because I'm just
following the breadcrumbs and so to put
all of my art into this one place and to
look at it and read through it myself it
was almost like I realized what I've
been trying to say all of these years
it's revealing itself to you yes exactly
that's super interesting right because
when I look at the book first of all you
know a lot of these poems certainly not
all of them but a lot of them I've heard
you perform many times but the
experience of reading it is very
different of course I have your voice in
my head as I'm reading it and I'm trying
to recall like your particular points of
inflection and emphasis is undoing it
but it quickly is very apparent that
there is an intentionality in the
ordering of these poems yeah and that
you know a sort of character arc or a
hero's journey begins to emerge and I
know you've broken the book up into two
discreet kind of phases one is about
your own personal transformation and
then it kind of shifts focus to how do
you use that transformation to transform
the world right but they're all in
lockstep with each other in this really
beautiful jigsaw puzzle that I was
unaware of because I've just heard you
perform individual poems and I never
really thought much about how these
poems inter relate to each other
mm-hmm but this greater sense of the
whole begins to kind of percolate as you
immerse yourself in the work yeah I mean
first of all I'm really glad to hear
that you felt that when you read it I
mean the idea of inquire within first of
all my name in queue is in question and
really in question was the second
incarnation of it the first was inquiry
so inquire within you know it just
kind of makes sense and I've had that
name since I was fifteen years old but
it really also is the central theme to
all of the content in the book because
as we're discussing you know with
technology there's all these incredible
opportunities I mean there's no way for
us to quantify the ripples of even this
podcast who hears it how they're
impacted by it
you know what you've created I mean you
have really no idea the changes that
people are making or the inspiration
that they feel when they continue to
come back to you as an artist and listen
to the things that you put out into the
world that's really an unbelievable
opportunity for us to continue to use
our voices in ways that no one has ever
had the opportunity in the history of
the world but you know it's also very
isolating and people are not connecting
in the same ways that they used to and
they're not taking time to be on their
own I mean we're basically trained by
consumerism I mean everything wants
something from us it wants our money it
wants our time it wants our attention it
once our likes it wants our love and
since we're always like looking outside
of ourselves for the answers if I don't
know something I look on Google you know
I I listen to a podcast I go to a book
and all of these things are absolutely
amazing but as I said it's the
difference between you using a tool and
a tool using you and so just to be
silent for a while and to listen to your
own true voice because that is going to
be the compass that is going to move you
forward in life the way that you want to
be moved forward and I would say
ultimately that's the lesson that I've
been trying to teach myself over and
over with my poetry is to be quiet
enough to hear my own voice because that
voice always tells me what I need and
where I need to go next
well implicit in the title inquire
within is that those answers reside
within yourself yeah right and we're in
a culture as you mentioned where
everything is about externalities and
there's no
no driving force telling us you know
affirming that those answers are within
ourselves right instead we're constantly
questioning ourselves or were unlikely
to trust that voice right and instead
look to the experts or who does you know
what does that guy doing or what are
that person saying right and I think
that that's part of the problem of
hero-worship and in the culture as well
it's like you know we look at our heroes
and we just project all of this [ __ ]
onto them and then we resent them when
they don't live up to our imaginary
projections of their perfection you know
and they reinforce it often but that's
why I tend to be drawn to people who are
very honest about their own human
struggle because I think that's more
interesting it's more interesting for me
to look at somebody who I feel like is
human and is dealing with all of these
different things but is still willing to
wake up every day and strive to be the
best version of themselves that they can
be because then their accomplishments
are something I can look at and say wow
that inspires me rather than something
that discourages me you know because
they're so amazing that they're almost
like separate from me and I could never
achieve something like that and so I
think that that takes us being more
honest about all of our processes you
know and not just the product well
that's what I was gonna say it's just
honesty right everybody's going through
[ __ ] right it's a question of whether
you're willing to be transparent about
that or not right the way that you hold
yourself out to the world we're all
wearing masks you know and and you know
there's a difference between our
interior lives and that which we project
onto the world or what we want people to
know and and I think there's a place for
you know privacy in that regard but I
think there is something super
refreshing about the person who is
willing to you know fess up to those
struggles and and those are the people
that to me just feel that I'm more drawn
to and attracted to because of that
honesty there's a trustworthiness I
think
comes with I agree yeah absolutely how
do you think about that as you you know
comport yourself in public well first of
all I need to know what comport means
how you hold yourself out you know what
I mean like on some level you're a
public figure yeah you're known for your
art but you're you know you're in the
world and I would imagine people project
onto you a certain idea of who you are
and how you think about yourself is
probably different from whatever that
projection is yeah I mean I'm a work in
progress like everyone else and I think
you know if people project on to me it's
because they maybe see some sort of a
finished product in a poem you know and
they think oh this is something that he
fully embodies rather than something
that I am embodying right you you wrote
it because you're trying to work it out
for your so a hundred percent yeah yeah
and that's what's fun is you know I get
to continue you know it's not like I'm
gonna run out of material you know
because I'm always going to be searching
for something new I was having a
conversation with someone yesterday and
we were talking about it was some birds
that were chirping and in the background
she was like in a beautiful place in
nature
and we were just discussing the birds
and I was just saying basically like the
birds aren't trying to win a Grammy
right you know
right they're not trying to go platinum
and I was like that's the start of a
poem you know because that's something
that's moving and meaningful and
interesting to me and I still have that
within myself that you know the things
that I'm trying to create of course I
still want to be validated you know my
ego wants people to like Who I am and to
be successful and all of that stuff but
me striving for that validation actually
gets in the way of the true
communication that I want and that the
poems want because they were written
from this moment of truth and they have
a desire to be expressed in their truest
nature and so that's why I think I'm the
vehicle and also the option for them
how long do these poems ferment and age
in the wine cellar before you release
them on to the world like I I suspect
there's a gestation period where they're
kind of evolving over time and that
there's a window in which you know you
allow them that space to ultimately
become what they become before you share
them is there a timeframe on that
typically for you just some of these
happen really quickly some of them take
a lot of time and even some of the ones
that you've been performing for a long
time do you make edits to them do you
change them or are they just you put
them aside and say these are finished
works well they've always been living
breathing documents before the book
because this is the first time they're
written down this is literally the first
time about notebooks though I mean
tomorrow you have an incredible memory
like you're able to recall I don't know
how you are able to do that but I would
imagine you've got tons of notebooks at
home yeah before I transferred to
writing on my iPhone I had notebooks on
notebooks on notebooks but they were
always like crossed out and you know
impossible to read and and so like those
mmm you see those notes about M&M and
it's just like there's no room on the
page and just tons yes you know what I'm
talking about
yeah I've actually M&M writes in a
really interesting way that I've seen
when he writes on pages too because he
writes like in different pockets if my
memory it's not linear there's like
little circles and it's all over the
place like it's a crazy diagram yeah
which is cool to see a representation of
how an artist creates you know for me it
was very you know big crosses out and
big letters and all over the place you
know but definitely like in a linear way
but then it was difficult to edit
because I would have to go back and
forth and when I transferred it over to
the iPhone the cut and paste made my
editing process a lot cleaner
you know the poems all have a different
gestation period some of them have taken
six months before some of them have
taken you know six hours and then I
guess some have taken a half an hour and
they just kind of pour out of me
and they're always different and
sometimes I'll get to a place where I've
written maybe half of the poem and I
don't know where it's supposed to go
next and I just kind of assumed that I
haven't lived enough and I just go out
and live a little bit more and then all
of a sudden I'm like oh this is where
the poem wants to go and so I'm not like
in a rush I don't force it to come out
of me and I do think that strategizing
inspiration is dangerous because you're
trying to control something that is made
of infinite possibilities right there is
a discipline to what you do but so much
of it is about the allowing right and
getting out of the way and becoming as
clear of a channel as you possibly can
exactly so you know people ask me oh how
long have you been working on this book
and I'm like well about a year you know
but then you know the oldest poem in the
book is probably 14 years old and that
poem took me like 10 years to write
right pretty much so I'm like 25 years
pretty much I've been working on the
truest answer is it took me my whole
life
right exactly there's not about how long
it took you to construct a poem it's the
expression of a life lived that's right
and then it's also not only the poem
that's created but the giving away of
the poem
you know the Miles Davis quote I'm gonna
butcher it but it has something to do
with it took me my whole life to be able
to play like myself mm-hmm
you know and really truly being able to
show up and you know give it away you
know I think that's something certainly
I'm still learning but more and more I'm
able to really land when I'm performing
well that becoming yourself is part and
parcel with the getting out of the way
but the becoming yourself is all the
work that you did to you know do battle
with your demons and overcome these
resentments and all these you know
things that you had to contend with
emotionally psychologically to become a
more self actualized human being right
that
have the clarity to be able to you know
grapple with these ideas and convey them
in a in a clear manner yeah for sure so
that ultimately is what I hope that the
book is I hope it's a window into people
finding their own voice it's you know
inquire within the pages of the book
it's that I had to enquire with them
myself to create it and that the person
that reads it
it's an invitation really for them to
inquire within themselves what's
interesting and what I didn't expect
reading the book is that it's almost
memoir and poetry at least the first
part of it is clearly like I was
expecting I thought like oh there's
gonna be poems but it's going to be
punctuated with more of your own writing
maybe expository or just stuff about
your life to kind of contextualize your
perspective but it's not that you go
right into the there's you know you tell
little stories here and there then
aren't in poetry format right
technically but it's really you
revealing yourself through these poems
that you've written mm-hmm yeah and it
does function like a memoir in a very
interesting way it I've never seen
anything like that before yeah I'm glad
to hear you say that I mean we
definitely you know we didn't want to
strategize the inspiration but we did
want to strategize the conceptual
through line and I wanted there to be
this poetic hero's journey in the first
half I mean there's there's two halves
to the book there's inhale and there's
exhale and inhale is the personal
journey everything that I went through
and then exhale is more social and
political and it's the idea of changing
yourself and then changing the world as
above so below and so it was definitely
something that we thought of consciously
in the creation of it you know that it
would have this jagged poetic conceptual
through on and then when you add in the
illustrations that it would have almost
like a philosophical shel silverstein
feel to me where people would have an
opportunity to delve deeper into the
work by looking at these images that
have kind of layers of depth
yeah the illustrations are awesome yeah
who's the artist
most of shariq yeah this guy who lives
in LA
it was a really brilliant artist and he
came on and we worked with them a really
long time to create these images that
have a deeper meaning to them it's
pretty cool
it's gotta be well I was gonna say it's
a unique thing to put a book of poetry
out in the world but I think poetry is
kind of having a moment right now yeah
in a way that we haven't seen in a very
long time yeah
you know obviously we have rupee cowers
book that just like exploded for sure
Internet and I don't know how you think
about her or that book but it's it's
proof positive that people are
interested in this medium in a way that
I think a lot of people would not have
imagined absolutely and I think it's the
beginning of that wave I don't think
it's the end I think that poetry is
going to be a really huge genre in
popular culture I think in the next five
years I think so and I think it's going
to be very different from how people
perceive it right now I think the
possibility of what poetry can be is
just kind of scratching the surface and
I think poets are gonna have their own
specials and their own sitcoms and
beyond all the late-night talk shows and
everything like that and I think that we
need that type of voice right now in
popular culture a voice that speaks
truth to power but also truth to
illusion so rupee anybody out there who
is furthering the artform absolutely
support them and I'm really excited
whenever I see a new poet Brad ruin
someone do you know this guy George the
poet I know George oh you do from years
ago I was brilliant I loved his art I
was just reading about him the other day
because he's got this podcast now are
you familiar with this are you talking
about George Watsky
no this is no last name he's a British
dude I don't know dude goes by Georgia
poet I know a guy named George Watsky
was an incredibly poet you got to check
this out he's got he's got a and he's
he's a very from what I understand I'm
perhaps
I'm butchering this because I don't know
that much about this guy but I believe
that he is like a working-class kid from
Britain who ended up going to like
Cambridge like he's a very well-educated
guy and started his trajectory was
similar to your own and then he started
he got a music contract and he was doing
music and hip-hop and and you know that
he was he was expressing his art in that
vein until he had a moment not
dissimilar from the experience that you
described of doing his you know of doing
his art in a more spoken word format and
really connected with people and he's
become like a thing and he's got this
podcast now called
have you it's called have you heard
George's podcast and apparently I got to
check it out even listen to it you know
I was just reading about it but he he
we've spoken word with all different
kinds of sounds and cool like you know
from nature from technology from music
and he creates this kind of auditory
experience that was quite unique that
people are really cutting onto I'll
definitely check it out I just think so
like ironic names for podcasts I know
have you heard George's pot that's a
great perfect man I know it's very
cheeky but it's to your point of of this
medium being pushed forward and given
like a modern veneer you know it's like
like okay this is what we think of
poetry being what if we brought in these
other auditory elements and wove those
and like this constant reinvention you
know that we see in music all the time
yeah but we think of poetry as a very
static medium yeah for sure now yeah and
I'm excited for that I'm excited for
where it is and where it's going and I'm
excited for where it came from because I
mean the community that I came from was
absolutely brilliant and still is I mean
some of my most amazing art experiences
were as an audience member you know
watching other poets and being blown
away by them just getting onstage and
the simplicity of expressing a story
through either poetic rhythms or rhymes
and just watching how
other people and I was moved by that
well there's a there's a there's a
difference between poetry in and of
itself and the performance of the poetry
right right there was a day in an age
when poetry existed outside of of that
performative element of it like yeah you
look at you know I don't know
Robert Frost Walt Whitman Henry David
Thoreau like they weren't performed is
to my knowledge they weren't getting up
and doing it in front of groups of
people know what I would love to write
so it makes me think like if if if that
sensibility was born in a young person
today I would imagine they're gonna get
directed towards hip-hop or perhaps now
with the growing medium of spoken word
performance that they would find their
their groove in that in that discipline
yeah I mean first of all however anybody
finds creativity in whatever genre they
find it in I'm stoked because right now
people need to use their voices more
than any other time in history and they
have the ability through technology to
do that and so everyone absolutely needs
to be pursuing their creative voice in
any way that they can but you know for
me if I think of what you were just
discussing I mean seeing Robert Frost
live would have been [ __ ] rad you
know like Rumi I've heard in the native
language it rhymed you know so how
incredible would that have been to see
Rumi perform you know the poems live I
mean because I think that the rhymes are
almost like a window into another
rhythmic spiritual dimension and so you
know yeah it's not only the creation of
it it's the sharing of it and I would
say that that's not only for people who
are professional poets but for anyone
who's creating art I mean there is a
completion in the giving away there is a
release when you allow it to not be
yours anymore when you allow someone
else to interpret it in whatever way
that they feel and that's why I don't
really have
a strategy of how I want my audience to
feel when they hear my work however they
feel and whatever it is that happens to
them is what they need to take and even
when we were creating the audio book
which we just finished and I'm so
[ __ ] excited about it man like both
of these the actual book having
something that people can hold in their
hands and experience the illustration
and then the audio book you know and all
of the different voices and styles that
I used in the book that are actually
showing up when people can listen to it
you know the intention of making
something that people could listen to
completely focused on or in a passive
way uh-huh you know while they're
[ __ ] vacuuming and then whatever
sentence pops out that they needed to
hear is the one that they needed to hear
that's what we were kind of able to do
was just like combine the feeling of me
being on stage in front of 1,500 people
with me talking to one person and having
that intimacy still there that's what's
exciting is whatever it is that people
need to take that's theirs it's not mine
anymore you know what I think is cool is
that with things like this usually
somebody will buy the audio book or the
book yeah but when you were performing
that poem at the outset I was following
along on the page yeah I could see
people doing both because they want to
see it there's something about visually
seeing the words that at least for me
like help route it in my consciousness
but I also want to know how you perform
it right to be able to experience those
in tandem yeah I think would be its own
unique experience as well yeah and then
you know if people take shrooms or
whatever and [ __ ] do both
simultaneously yeah I mean that they're
just really inquiring with yeah exactly
I think that I mean it's not something
that I haven't not thought of no I
definitely you know like anything else
sometimes you can delve deeper if if you
get kind of into a different level of
consciousness and so you know certainly
that's there's the invitation for that
as well
right now when you were recording the
audiobook so I assumed you were just
performing like you're performing the
poems the way that you would in front of
an audience but you're going through the
whole book or was there something
additional that you did in that that
made it special for you well I would say
you know that this experience of writing
the book was the biggest opportunity for
me to evolve as an artist there's
nothing else that I've ever done that
has brought this much growth to me as a
poet and so specifically now when we're
talking about the audiobook when I first
went to record it I was recording it
just like I would perform on stage and
what I realized and listening back to it
is that was the wrong approach because
it's not something where I'm performing
to a large group of people it's really
where I'm talking to one person mmm and
really communicating with one person how
did that change your delivery I had to
find an area in my voice that allowed me
to hold on to the passion but also to
have it contained in the intimacy and
that was an interesting thing to find
but I really was able to find it and
create something that I'm unbelievably
proud of you know I was listening to it
on the way over because we're just doing
it like Glassman and edits and it
doesn't get boring at all I was like 40
minutes in and every single time you
know there's a stylistic change or a
conceptual change that allows you to
ride the next wave and I'm really
excited to give it away and have it be
whatever it needs to be from people you
had told me previously that writing this
book was like the hardest thing you've
ever done
yeah explain that to me because it's
easy to look at the book and just go
well it's just a collection of your
poems right how hard could that be right
yeah and that's what I thought you have
you have you've got some cool
illustrations and you play around with
with typeset and fonts where's that one
poem where it starts off really tiny and
gets a little bit bigger like you do
some interesting cool things well that's
really that one specific
like for example that sound the alarm
and so the reason that we did it that
it's very small and then it just kept
getting bigger and bigger because the
actual poem gets faster and faster so
when you're listening to it in the
audiobook it's sounding alone something
is wrong people are tired of living to
count but then it winds up being sound
the alarm something is wrong people are
tired to live in the calm we can and
we're gonna walk into you know that type
of thing so we wanted to find a way to
visually represent the style of how I do
it live on a page so there was a lot of
just that man it was like exploring my
work in a way that I never had it was
editing my work in a way that I never
had since they've always been these
living breathing documents that they
would change as I would change and you
never had to think about how it would be
presented visually no right how do you
convey cadence and speed right on a page
right or a motion yeah you know how do
we how do we create a motion on a page
you know separate from the illustrations
in where it is on the page how do I put
rhythm on a page so all of those things
were interesting and then you know just
me looking at all of my material and
saying alright these edits that I'm
making right now I can't just change
them in real time if I evolve you know I
have to make sure that what I'm saying
is something that as to the best of my
ability is something that I'll stand
behind in 20 years or 30 years so I
think there was a different level of
like intention in the final decisions
that we made so I think those were two
of the reasons that it was a complicated
process but an amazing one then I think
getting through the mountain of writing
the book and putting it in the
conceptual order that really made sense
because I wanted people to have the
experience of picking up the book and
having the option after they read it
through from beginning to end to just
choosing a poem but I didn't really just
want it to be a thing where they just
flipped through and looked at a poem I
wanted them to have the experience at
least of few
the poetic story that we were trying to
create so anything that was unnecessary
it didn't matter if it was a great poem
I took it out because I wanted the story
to take you somewhere yeah my my first
inclination when I got the galley which
I know you you want you you want people
to see like like a an excellent like
control freak
after my own heart exam but before I
even read a page I kind of flipped
through it just to get a sense of like
how this thing is structured and I was
like oh it's it's basically all poetry
it's not you know it's you know it's
it's not what I thought it might be and
and then I thought well this is gonna be
that kind of book that you could crack
open mmm but then you know I just go to
the first page and you know basically
you're like part 1 part 1 inhale and I
was like oh mmm that's not gonna be the
way that this goes and then you read the
first poem and you're like oh this is
the beginning of a bigger story mmm like
you're gonna have to read this all the
way through from beginning to end yes at
first yeah right and then interestingly
enough now in the audiobook hearing it
from beginning to end that story comes
through in a different way uh-huh so
even for me man you know it was like
listening to it was like listening to my
poems for the first time and it was
actually nice for me because I got a
chance to experience them from the
outside looking in you also do these
interesting things with like page breaks
and where you place the text on the page
like in this growing up poem yeah was
this I mean it's kind of an EE
Cummings thing that you're doing here a
little bit is this the way it looks in
your notebooks or did you have did you
think intentionally like about how you
wanted it to look written down for the
first time when you were putting know
all the formatting stuff is unique to
the book you know when I write I just
pretty much write and I'm much more
interested in getting it out I don't
really care how it looks at that point
you know and and yet
now I'm so excited about this because
you know I'm taking my own advice
finally you know which is that if you
create something you have to truly give
it away in order to release it and move
on so for this to have a new life for
other people there was almost like a
mini death for me but it was beautiful
and so now I'm super excited to see well
what am I going to create next and now
even in creating it in the back of my
mind I'm like well then how would I
format this you know which is never
something I even considered right in the
sense in the same way that a comic who
does a special now has to kind of retire
that material right because she been you
know doing these poems for a long time
right right see time to turn the page I
don't think I'll ever fully retire them
but I do think that there is going to be
a sense of release uh-huh I already feel
it and I feel a sense of ownership and I
also feel a sense of just completely
giving it away yeah how do you reconcile
the control freak who you know wants you
know everything perfect on this cart
like it's a chore we start the podcast
as I call that's the gallied know the
new book looks so much better and I wish
they did this whole thing right how do
you how do you you know reconcile that
with this the important notion that in
order to do what you do you have to let
go of perfectionism and be in that
allowing like you can't let you know
that attachment to perfection be the
enemy of good so to speak right as the
average goes like you have to be in the
flow right yeah there's a there's that
allowing and then there's also that like
clamping down to make it just so yeah I
mean I think both are important and both
are necessary and I think if we're gonna
take the book as an example there was
never a place and I was very very
conscious of this where
I was over editing in a way that was
actually hurting the project and I think
that's the thing that people need to be
conscious of you know when they're
thinking about the side of themselves
that's controlling is there's a
difference between making a project
better because you have attention to
detail and you're meticulous and you
care about the thing that you're putting
out into the world you want it to be the
best it can possibly be to be
world-class to know that you left no
stone unturned and then actually
clipping the bonsai tree to the point
where it's just branches you know and
only you will know like anything else
but if you're aware of that razor's edge
that you're walking I think it makes the
walk easier yeah yeah it's gotta be hard
though yeah you know I mean how do you
do it I don't know I don't know I wish I
I wish I had that kind of clarity to be
able to articulate it I think I have a
tendency to get too caught up in tiny
details that don't matter and I lose the
forest for the trees that's unlike a
recurring pattern that I'm always doing
more with mmm I'm okay with it in the
moment like right now I'm trying to be
present but in the back of my mind I'm
like is this going okay am I gonna run
out of questions
I feel pretty okay I gotta just come
back to the present because if I'm
paying attention to what cue us to say
like we're good you know I mean so that
is not something that you normally go
through when you're doing podcasts does
that happen every time or I mean it
depends on who you're talking to
yeah but I go into everyone wanting it
to be you know I set a high bar for
myself and I think I want this to be the
definitive conversation of all time with
that person right so automatically I'm
setting myself up for disappointment and
failure but you're also setting yourself
up to do the absolute yes that you can
that is the intention that I go into it
with but that pressure also can get in
the way yeah because whether or not this
is a conversation that's going to be
inspiring and helpful to other people is
in large part
function of how much I can get out of
the out of the way
yeah and allow it to be what it wants to
be but it's the same thing it's that
concept we were talking about earlier
you're the vehicle and the obstacle for
it because at all times literally at all
times and me too I mean like for example
I want the same thing I want this to be
the definitive conversation with rich
roll like a hundred percent you know but
the reality is is that all I can do is
show up and be myself and all you can do
is show up and do yourself and be
prepared and do our best and then
ultimately however anyone takes this
it's not my [ __ ] yeah it's not my
business you know like and so I think
it's the same thing with with the book
or any piece of art that you create and
if you try to control how someone else
you know perceives you it's a waste of
energy if you try to control how someone
else takes a piece of art it's a waste
of energy and I'd rather take that
energy or that anxiety or whatever it is
the uncertain is the wanting to control
and use it to work on something that I
can control or work on something that I
can create and then in that way I think
I'm alkalizing that energy mm-hmm I'm
just processing all that it's uh it's
it's so much easier said than done it is
you know and I go through my own ups and
downs with it yeah you know I think you
know for me the problem the problem is
and and probably always will be like ego
you know it's like the ego gets in the
way right because the ego wants you to
be positioned in a manner so you will be
perceived by the outside world and then
if you can do that then you're gonna get
that affirmation that you think you want
that you need to be happy but in truth
all you have to do is inquire within it
right don't bring it back I'm definitely
gonna put on my social media yeah yeah I
want to I want to talk about
the idea like that the the fleeting
nature of life which permeates so much
of your poetry right it's a constant
reminder to like come back to the
present and that it's the little things
that matter and it's about paying
attention to what is like you told the
little story earlier about the birds
like not trying to win the Grammys right
like that kind of encapsulates that idea
that life is happening now yeah and
we're so distracted from ourselves and
everything that's going on around us
that we miss the most important things
yeah I mean nature has an ego but only
for survival you know like I for example
when you were talking about ego earlier
I don't think we can ever get rid of our
ego because our ego is it's what it
means to be alive you know is to is to
have separation in the illusion that's
what allows us to have our identity so I
think ego is necessary but operating
from ego can get me in trouble
and so it's unlearning that process over
and over and over again and nature can
be a great teacher in that way because
Nature has ego for the survival aspect
of things but a cheetah doesn't care how
it's perceived when it's running mm-hmm
you know I mean it an elephant isn't
insecure right you know what I mean
so I think and are we weirdly like the
only animal that pretends to be
something other than what we are in
order to navigate this Julie always says
this I don't know where she got it but
it's something along the lines of we're
not we're not I'm gonna butcher this but
it's it's something along the lines of
like you know frog isn't pissed because
he's not a bird or we're not angry at
the Frog because he can't fly right you
know we we but with human beings we
project onto ourselves and other people
this expectation that they need to be
something that they're not right well
forsaking celebrating what they actually
are yeah like you need to fit into this
and if you if you can't you know check
all these boxes then you're less than
right let's do like what is so awesome
about you it's that's you know focus on
that I think that probably comes from
the tribal thing you know I mean in the
hunter-gatherer times I think one of the
main sources of like death was like
murder
she would literally like see someone
from another tribe you just murder them
you know I mean like and these hundred
person groups of people you know if you
were outside of that and you had to deal
with nature survival survival men and so
we're all walking around on this like
pre-programmed you know we got to fit in
I got to make sure everyone likes me or
else but you know it's [ __ ] boring
and you know we're all so beautiful and
so unique and I'm just much more
interested in in following my enthusiasm
to see what's next yeah we are
hard-wired for tribalism I love your
short little poem about ideas versus
ideology I like that which is it's a
trap right because we all want to thank
or believe that we're about the ideas
and we're not about the ideology right
and the minute you commit to being
somebody about ideas you've hence formed
an ideology right exactly so that's it
so the story I'll just tell it because I
tell it in the book I was coming out of
my therapists office and we have been
discussing the differences between ideas
and ideologies and by the way this is
just a separate thing but you know
anytime somebody's like oh like therapy
like why are people talking [ __ ] about
therapy like don't you want a coach for
your [ __ ] life man like seriously
like who the [ __ ] is talking [ __ ] about
therapy in 2020 it's a it's a remnant of
a bygone decade I think yeah it's like
residue of a past decade that looked
that frowned upon that kind of thing if
you're doing that you're damaged yeah I
want a girl [ __ ] damaging exactly
like so whatever so we were discussing
the differences between ideas and
ideologies and this was his philosophy
he was saying that ideas are tools that
you can use in your life that changes
your truth in your
it's changes but ideologies are prisons
that you have to force everything in
your reality into the frame of otherwise
you'll lose control over that ideology
and that part of your life because in
ideology becomes a part of your identity
so then if you're letting go of the
ideology you're letting go of your
identity you're [ __ ] dying and you'll
do anything to not let go of your
identity right so then I was like oh I
only want to use ideas then and then
that was the whole thing is but from now
on I'm only gonna use ideas and then
[ __ ] I just created a new idea right
exactly
I think it's very emblematic of our
current moment mmm when you go online
and we're all siloed and virtue
signaling to our respective tribes and
trying to be upstanding members of
whatever ideology that represents and at
the same time protesting that we are
partaking in a restrictive ideology yeah
yeah exactly that and it's really it's
denigrating not just public discourse
but and our institutions but I think the
moral the moral and emotional fabric of
everybody yeah and we can't even respect
people who have a different opinion
anymore I mean we look at them like I
can't even have a conversation know that
we dehumanize each other you know and
look there are many many things that I
do not agree with opinion wise you know
of different people who are out there
but also you have to take into
consideration the environments that
they're in I mean like and this is
actually a departure of what we're
talking about but you know think about
the poem that I did earlier about my dad
or my mom like my mom is an incredible
incredible human being she's a
schoolteacher that raised me on her own
and yeah you know we have a complicated
relationship but she's layered and she's
deep and she's so intelligent and she
has been there for me more than anyone
else ever has in my whole entire life
and so I have this deep respect for her
but you know in the time
you break apart in your teenage years
which is necessary to form your
independence you have to judge your
parents yeah it's a part of the process
you know so experiencing it right now
I'm sure you are and I'm happy to
discuss that it is a necessity to them
really truly allowing freedom is to look
back and judge but the full circle of
that is ultimately you you at a certain
point realize your parents aren't God
you know when you grow up your parents
are your God and rightfully so they
teach you every single thing about life
including love what love even is you
know and so you look at them like God
and then when you separate you judge
them and then the full circle is
realizing that your parents had parents
and their parents had parents and it's
this infinite line of people and if I
judge anything my mom I am judging her
based on the life that she gave me that
I grew up in Santa Monica California
that I have all the experiences that I
have to look back on her life and
separate from that when in reality she
grew up in 1950s Brooklyn I have no
[ __ ] idea what that was like and I've
no [ __ ] idea what the environment of
a lot of these people who have differing
beliefs you know than I do right now in
this moment is like and why they have
different priorities but the only way to
find out is to actually communicate with
each other and not to humanize each
other how do you square that level of of
compassion and understanding the sense
of non judgment you know especially if
you haven't walked a mile in somebody's
shoes with the more political bending
poems that you've done like the I mean
your poem on gun violence is like super
powerful yeah thank you I really really
really want to retire it you know I
don't ever want to have to do that's a
poem that I want to retire any of the
social or political stuff out I hope
that I never have to perform them again
I wish I never had to write them but
right but you have conviction about the
issues yeah and you have performed them
in front of in you know in front of
people and so you know that's a very
that's a very different message from the
one of you know compassion I mean it's
compassion and it's directed in a
different manner I guess so you know
I've had people come up to me and say
that they changed their vote based on a
political piece that I put out and I
think that
now more than ever as I said before it
is a [ __ ] responsibility for everybody
to use their voice to stand up for the
things that they believe in and I do
think that dehumanizing other people in
the process is a real mistake
it's a cataclysmic mistake but not
speaking up for what you believe in is
an equal mistake and so I think we all
need to be speaking our mind speaking
our hearts even at the risk of being
wrong you know because there's a lot of
pieces that I do that are more social
and political that I know I'm gonna get
a part of them wrong you know that
they're naive you know there's pieces
I've done about racism for example I
don't know that experience fully myself
so it's gonna be a naive poem but I feel
that I have a responsibility to say
something that I'm passionate about and
something that I believe in to be a part
of the conversation because I think the
more people that talk about it the more
we can get to truth if we're actually
not only talking but listening so I not
only try to put out I try to listen to
the best of my ability and find that
middle ground how would you say that you
have changed or evolved since maybe I
mean when was the last time we did a
podcast had be coming years yeah it was
like maybe three or four years ago yeah
you know my sense of you is that you're
you're you're more grounded you're more
self-assured
and not just your art but in in your
life and your sense of who you are but
how do you think about that like what
are the things that you've kind of faced
and overcome in the in the in the years
since we sat down last well once again
that's kind of my same experience of you
like I kind of mirrored that
back to you I feel the same thing one of
the things that I really liked about
something that you put out recently was
you've been talking about how the things
that you've accomplished in life kind of
happened at a later age I remember that
list they put out and I was so that was
one of those things where it was
something that allowed me to go wow man
I can go farther I can go deeper I can
climb higher and it didn't make me feel
discouraged by accomplishments and made
me inspired by them so I felt like you
were walking the talk and talking the
walk by putting stuff like that out into
the world so I think that's where I'm at
is I think at a certain point I thought
I needed to do something or get
somewhere and I was chasing something or
running from something and I was always
exploring being here but I wasn't really
here and I mean in the past four years I
started meditating that's been an
absolute game changer I got a body work
coach that kind of helped me move
through some of the old unresolved
trapped emotion that I had in my system
and release it I think that brought me
more into the moment I'm in a great
relationship you know that really has
been amazing to learn how to love and be
loved unconditionally and so I think a
lot of those things have helped and then
also I think having more of a sense of
foundation in Who I am as an artist
rather than wanting you know rather than
eating yeah you know just more like
trusting and allowing which is a word
that you used earlier yeah all of those
things I think we're seeing that play
out with mike posner right now like this
massive jump in his personal evolution
where he's really taken a different turn
in his career like divorcing himself
from those externalities to live his
wife live his life and in a in a in a
different kind of intentional
I suppose and the way that he's sharing
it I think it's super inspiring but when
you were when you were explaining that I
was thinking of him like I'm seeing that
that's that's happening in real time
with him right now
I love what Mike's doing because Mike is
showing his process I mean first of all
he's one of my best friends and I
absolutely love him he's the boss but I
also love what he's doing mm-hmm
because he's really showing that whole
process like he's not only showing the
walk you know where I'm a hero and look
at this walk he showed the difficult
moments he showed what it took him to
get through those moments and that's
something that you know all the people
who were watching and following his
journey they get to mirror that back
onto their own journey and find those
little ways that they can overcome those
obstacles in their own lives and also
walking away from something that is
incredibly enticing
and and and you know I think for most
people would be difficult to imagine
like yeah you know the the kind of life
that he could be living doing what he
does
what is that life though you know like
well there's what we imagine it to be
and somebody who's experienced it and
and his sharing like listen it ain't all
cracked up you know it's not what you
think it is yeah and and the fact that
he you know is talking about how you
know it's not fulfilling in the way that
you you imagined it to be
there's never an end to more no there
just is never an end to more and so if
more of these super rich people with
tons of fancy cars do you know that are
super unhappy yeah come on yeah so I
think you know he experienced that and
he decided to walk in a different
direction you know in the world but also
within himself and so as his friend it's
been it's been really inspiring and also
mike is a true artist like and you know
that because you've seen him in every
single project that he do transform into
a new moment and it almost a new
identity not only in what he's talking
about but stylistically because it's him
following his enthusiasm and that
you know if you have success what do you
do you want to repeat it you know but
but who the [ __ ] wants to just repeat
something over and over again it's just
like that's boring as well it's like why
not be surprised by your own artistic
journey and yeah you might lose some
fans who said oh you you're not the
person that I fell in love with but
you'll find other ones because if you're
being honest and true to who you are as
an artist there's always gonna be
someone out there who goes that reminds
me of me and where I'm at yeah so how do
you take that and use it to fuel your
own you know kind of constant
reinvention with what you do I mean it's
just once again it's just paying
attention rather than trying to
strategize the inspiration right you
know I am really curious about this next
stage of what it is that I'll want to do
but right now I'm more focused and
excited on just the idea of finally
giving some earthly way to birthing this
thing yeah you know I mean one more idea
about Mike and yeah we'll move on but
but I think what what really strikes me
about him is that he's been able to
really protect his childlike nature like
there's a there's a purity to that guy
that is very rare
yeah and I see that and I and I yearn
for that in my own life like I feel like
it has escaped me hmm and to the extent
that we can venture back to that place
and create from you know from that
headspace and heart space that we all
knew innately as a child and I think is
is really you know a big part of what
makes his expression beautiful and why
it resonates what does that look like
for you like when have you experienced
that in your life that you can recall
and what was the feeling Linc I mean
it's hard to recall a specific moment
yeah you know my memory is is is clouded
you know what I think back but what I
connect with emotionally is
or what I try to imagine is that sense
of just childlike wonder you know that
that that is uncorrupted by any kind of
adult impulse that is standing as a
barrier between you and your
vulnerability mmm right yeah I mean look
what do musicians do they play you know
when I am going to a show I'm playing
I'm performing and even though it's what
I do for a living and I monetized it and
I have a brand or whatever the [ __ ] that
means if I lose that sense of play then
there is some sort of a gap between me
and possibility you know an imagination
you know so I think that's something
that I want to continue to remind myself
of as well you know not to get so into
the adult thing in life you know that I
kind of lose that play do you
consciously try to protect that I
consciously try to be a [ __ ] goofball
actually like I really do try to create
spaces that I can be a goofball and then
the other thing that I try to do is I
try to do [ __ ] that I'm really not good
at because it's very hard to be cool
when you're not good at something
uh-huh you know it's like whatever if
like if I go rock climbing or whatever I
am NOT gonna be [ __ ] cool when I'm
doing it and if you're gonna make all
those people in the workshop get up and
recite a poem then you've got to go out
in the world and do something that is
way you know far afield of what you're
comfortable now no totally because you
can't talk that talk unless you're
walking a hundred percent yeah I mean
and I and so I like doing things like
that and that's one of the reasons
actually that I love like traveling by
myself I travel often by myself and one
of the reasons that I love doing that is
because I get to show up in a place
where
no one knows who I am the language is
different the food is different I don't
know the streets and I don't even have a
friend or a partner that knows my story
or my identity so it's almost like the
clearest mirror that the world can give
you to how you're showing up in that
moment hmm you know I'm not in queue I'm
just some [ __ ] dirty to Adam who's
like wandering around the world and I
sometimes get my best ideas from that
because I'm in that place of force to
play and I try to then bring that back
to my life you know and different
activities that I do as well Henry
Rollins talks about that all the time
he's oriented his whole life around that
very thing plane traveling to remote
corners of the planet not places you
would go on vacation but like really off
the beaten path places most people don't
want to go yeah and he just shows up
with a backpack and nobody knows him he
doesn't he goes alone because he wants
to have an authentic experience yeah
that's how he can connect with himself
and I'm sure it informs you know his
version of what you do like his art yeah
I mean I love his art as well I mean
it's the world is so much bigger than
your insecurities yeah it's so huge man
you know and being in it is what a wild
[ __ ] ride this is you know one of the
things I've noticed about you and how
you live your life is is you seem to be
very conscious about surrounding
yourself with high vibe people yeah like
you got a solid crew grey crew that you
roll with yeah so how did you how did
you go from where you were to that place
and and did that just these are just
people who became your friends or was
there a concerted effort like hey I need
to really you know be conscious about
the vibration of the company that I keep
well I think it's like anything else you
know you're attracted to the frequency
that you're putting out so I think the
more that I focused my own frequency you
know and cleaned up my own energetic
field which I'm still doing you know the
clear that my
see was to attract somebody else who was
maybe on that same path so most of the
people that I spend time with our
seekers I don't give a [ __ ] about
success I mean that's cool you know but
I'm certainly don't give a [ __ ] about
money mm-hmm I care about somebody being
a good person
and I care about them striving to be a
better version of who they are on a day
to day basis and to seek to ask
questions about themselves and the
people that they spend time with and
their environment and humanity as a
whole
those are the things that really light
me up and then when I get a chance to be
around other people that are pursuing
that seekers mentality through a
different discipline than me they have a
different perspective to share with me
where is you know I have amazing amazing
poet friends that continue to enrich my
life in every possible way but we do
have a similar lens that we come from
whereas you know when I'm talking to
somebody else who does this or you know
does that and I have really no sense of
that in an experiential way they usually
give me a different tip tidbit and makes
me walk away and have a different
perspective on my own life and where I
can go what is that
seeking look like like what is that what
you know what would be like a practical
example of a friend of yours who is a
seeker like what are the characteristics
of that human being well we could take
Mike for example we could take you for
example I mean it's somebody who is
striving you know to move forward in
life and to be present in life and I
think that is the dichotomy of the
modern monk whatever that even means I
never said that before so you know I
don't don't make that my Instagram but
we found a title for this podcast yeah
exactly
who is the moderate Jesus no but but the
but really I mean when you're sitting on
mountaintop and you have no goals you
know and you just want to be present
being present is your only goal I mean
what an amazing life of service that is
I think that's really really beautiful
it's something that I look at and I'm
like wow I really respect that
and I admire it but that's not the life
I'm living you know there are things
that I want to accomplish and so it's
basically balancing those two worlds of
what I want to accomplish and also
knowing that there's nothing out there
mm-hmm
you know and so I would say that all of
my friends who are seekers usually are
balancing one foot in one of those
worlds and one foot in the other right
it's more about the relationship to the
achieving right and the difference being
one that is ego fueled versus one that
is sort of fueled more by a sense of
service or Purpose Driven yeah right I
mean that I think that's one of the
reasons that I responded to that post
that you made it's that when you get to
be a certain age you know you're
supposed to do this and do that
everything is so almost like robotic you
know and you're just kind of who you are
like this is now the dust is settled
yeah this is the way that it is but just
for purposes of clarity how're you now
I'm 42 42 all right well we've known
each other for a while and I can promise
you that the person that I was you know
at 42 32 what you know is just I'm
coming up from the rear man so I'm
trying to make hay while I can yeah I'm
very much a late bloomer in that regard
so it's not like oh I'm on this model
example of constant you know reinvention
so to speak it's just that I was you
know completely you know in my own way
for a very long time so I didn't begin
this process until much later right but
two things one thing that's funny is I'm
not 42 I'm 41 which is exactly the law
here what the [ __ ]
here's it said I literally got it wrong
right now you know I was getting a
haircut the other day and I was looking
at myself in the mirror and I was
thinking wow I am one haircut closer to
death you know and it was actually funny
to me it wasn't like you know cuz that's
a weird moment of you know checking in
every single time you get a haircut if
you took a picture you'd look at
yourself in the mirror and you'd be oh
incremental and accumulative least but
significantly older over time and yet
there's so much possibility because
everything that you just said it's like
wow what you've accomplished up until
now but what will you want to do
tomorrow I mean there isn't
yeah the dust has settled but in another
way you're gonna kick all the dust back
up again and reinvent yourself and I'm
curious who all be when I'm 70 what will
I dress like when I'm 80 years old
mm-hmm you know like what will I be
interested in what will I be curious at
that point and there's so many people
that I think feel trapped by the lives
that they've created for themselves and
I'm saying that as one of those people I
can relate to that but I always want to
undo that so that the the things that
I'm choosing to do are not obligations
you know I don't have to do anything
mm-hmm
you know I have some responsibilities
based on the life that I've created but
it's not that I even have to make a
different choice it's that I have to
understand that I have the choice to
make a different choice yeah I think
that that it's important to understand
that even if you're living a great life
you can still be a prisoner of that life
because we come so we've become so
habituated to whatever routines are
comfortable to us right that we
perpetuate them and becomes hard I will
say as somebody who's 53 and I am 53
being honest about that that you do
become you know the calcification
becomes harder and harder to confront
and overcome right because we're
creatures of habit right and when
something's working you keep doing it
and it's a discipline
to continually confront those patterns
and ask yourself like is this serving me
or even if it is let's redirect right
and you know I've been doing like the
show is an example I'm like well I guess
I'm a podcaster and I do this like I
actually have a choice this could be the
very last episode that I ever do is
available to me yeah that's not gonna
make that choice but just to remind
myself that I don't have to keep doing
that yeah because there's a lot of
momentum behind it doesn't mean that
it's a foregone conclusion you you could
decide that you're just never gonna
write a poem again and you're never
gonna perform again I don't have to be a
[ __ ] poet you and Michael we're just
gonna go hike mountains well you can
join us it'll just be a musician podcast
you know what the [ __ ] where what you
know I mean it's not that we have to
make a different choice it's that once
you know that you are making the choice
you're not a prisoner of it you have the
freedom to look at the reality that
you're in in a different way and so I I
am curious I mean I know that that
calcification process has happened and I
know that it will happen more but I also
know you know I could decide I want to
go river rafting tonight and I could
just leave here and go you know I mean
it's it's just it's more interesting to
me to look at my life like that because
there's more possibility right with
respect to the book we talked about how
somebody's reaction to your art is none
of your business and you know once you
kind of put it out into the world it
becomes public domain right it's you you
are you are relinquishing ownership over
this yeah piece of work right at the
same time I still imagine that you have
a sense of what you want people to take
away from this so if you had to
articulate that what does that look like
I had a friend once that said only you
will know I was like one of her mantras
when I would be discussing something
she would be discussing something with
someone else where they had that
specific issue they were working on and
you know she would talk it out with them
and then at a certain point she would
say only you will know and I think
that's what inquire within is about so
this is supposed to be a doorway for
someone to connect with that in a voice
within themselves and I hope that they
wind up finding whatever it is that they
might not have even known they were
looking for and that that leads them to
more fulfilling an empowered life so
these are broad things that I think when
someone picks up this book I don't have
anything specific because I think then I
would be confining people you know to
what I want
rather than whatever it is they need I
look at it
so much of what I get out of it is is
permission right permission to be
vulnerable permission to forgive like I
think a lot of people were were victims
of these emotional loops that we run
that are playing these tapes around who
we resent how we were wronged right and
and and we're the ones who are suffering
as a result
totally and and here there's there's a
sense of freedom that you explore by
giving yourself permission to forgive
those who have wronged you by by
engaging in self-love right and you see
this evolution from somebody who was in
pain and who has been wronged and who
has suffered to this freedom and this
lightness that comes with gratitude and
love and forgiveness yeah and life is
really [ __ ] beautiful man I mean it's
hard it's painful but it's beautiful and
I want to be living in that curiosity
living in that beauty
that possibility and this book has been
my roadmap to getting here I think
that's a good place to put a pin in it
great I want to end with a poem but
before we do that do you yeah I presume
you're gonna go on a book tour and do
the whole rigmarole with all of them
right everything that gets baked into
that including great word podcasts and
stuff are you gonna be performing yeah
we're doing a big show in LA at the
palace we're doing a big show in New
York a big show in San Francisco and
then we'll do like DC and Seattle and a
bunch of different cities so we'll do
these public shows and then I think
we'll do different bookstores and things
of that nature as well and then we'll do
a longer tour in the fall but I have a
bunch of videos that are gonna be coming
out as well around this and you know
really excited for people to experience
the book and the audiobook and look
self-promotion has been probably the
least thing that I enjoy and the least
thing that I'm good at in being a brand
whatever that even means you know but
I'm not uncomfortable promoting this
book like it's actually been a joy
because I see it is a separate thing
from me and I know that the book wants
to have a life of its own and wants to
get into as many people's hands as it
can or as many people's ears as it can
so this is a [ __ ] exciting process
for me to get out there and spread the
word well beautiful and well-earned
Thank You Man you're you're doing the
tour with conscious city guide yeah yeah
but know who I actually met at the event
I did yeah she's the best she's awesome
man so thank you for that yeah of course
she's been producing our retreats for
ever and what she's built with conscious
City guide is really quite something so
yeah yeah yeah yeah she gets a job done
for sure yeah it'll be cool well super
excited for you pick up the book inquire
within from independent bookstores if
you don't have one go to Amazon all that
good places go to
what's your website is it in Q comm it's
n - Q in question so I and - Q calm and
then you know all the social media stuff
is in Q life right take us out with the
poem alright this is called learned fear
learned fear can be overcome when you
realize the voice inside your head is
not yours it's an imitation of the
voices from before repeating on a loop
inside your quiet core receiving since
you youth when your choices weren't even
yours perceiving was the proof but
reality has many doors so why are we
still fighting other people's Wars
learned fear can be overcome when you
realize the voice inside your head is
not yours it's an imitation of the
voices from before repeating repeating
repeating on a loop inside your quiet
core and you can't tell the difference
because it sounds the same but trust me
when I tell you most of what you think
is from somebody else's brain they have
us trained shackled by imaginary chains
imaginary rules for imaginary games but
they don't know the reasons either so
where should we place the blame and who
is they anyway when we're all the same
our parents had parents and their
parents had parents apparently it hurts
to see so I'll be transparent the world
is so much bigger than your insecurities
and they don't speak on your behalf
without your Souls Authority the world
is so much bigger than your culture or
community and they don't speak on your
behalf without your Souls Authority
because if it's all a story then nobody
else can tell it for me since I'm always
transforming I defy a category when you
do the same thing the same way it's
habit forming but nothing in this land
of mortal
man is mandatory it's all just
transitory our world's a laboratory
experimenting on today can change
tomorrow morning
and since matter is mostly empty space
we're in a sea of consciousness where
the boundaries are erased so I stared at
my reflection until I couldn't see my
face then I picked myself and put the
flowers in an empty vase if you came for
validation then you're in the wrong
place the only certain satisfaction is
becoming what you've chased and there's
no running from the inner voice so it's
important that you choose but it's more
important that you know you have a
choice you have a choice are you living
someone else's life you have a voice
does it haunt you in the dead of night
would you fly if you weren't convinced
to be afraid of heights and who
convinced you anyway they had no [ __ ]
right right
no one can dim your light you shine
within so bright that you could blind
the Sun from sight and scare him back
into the night no one can dim your light
I said it twice because you're greater
than the circumstances that surround
your perfect life you're not your nature
or your nurture you're a prototype and
if you hone it right eventually you'll
hack your satellite at first is nothing
then nothing turns into a whisper turn
the dial and it gets crisper and your
transistor wait a while and the whisper
turns into a scream it overwhelms your
system and you won't know what it means
but pump the volume up and it can tell
you all your dreams till pretty soon
it's the only voice you'll ever need now
you have to do is listen when you want
to lead your fear disintegrates when you
decide
stop and breathe it's your authentic
voice no matter where you go it never
leaves and that's God no matter what
religion you believe I'm starting my own
religion and everyone is welcome but
nobody can join if you did you'd miss
the point love you man
love you too brother thank you so much
stay true dear youtubers peace
[Music]